you know
thank you
so it is
um
[Music]
remember
alrighty how
are we missing
board
okay let's go ahead and start
as soon as we start the sooner we get
out of here how are you doing Linda
and Valerie you're here and Muriel
you're here
uh everybody else we said good morning
we'll say good afternoon now
well if the odds are pretty good I'd be
right this this summer
or a humid day or just plain crummy day
yeah on this uh nice one out there today
so we got two bills
relative to the calculation average
daily membership in a tennis and the
average daily membership in residence
for school districts
and the other one
relative to the local education
Improvement plans and disparities in
education
so let's just go in sequential order
here 625
so let's look at 625
does everybody recall what this woman is
about
it's you know overall it's it's about
the
0.15 FTE that the school district will
get if a kid comes into a high school
class
and for reimbursement from the state in
terms of adequacy
the
the bill is proposing
that this be relative to two uh School
academic courses in grades one through
twelve
so but there we're open for discussion
one of our Prime shakers and Bakers of
those things represent cordelli he's
here
and
one of the things that I think you
talked about in the hearing was how do
you define
the mic the mic thank you one of the
things we talked about in the hearing
was how do you define the the 0.15 ETC I
had that in my notes anyway
and that was a question which we had
um you have in the high school of course
to find courses yeah
in Middle School you have a lot of that
same type of
block scheduling or scheduling occurring
in the high school dealing with courses
very few of the junior high schools
middle schools now are basically uh
taking the elementary model
um and then the elementary model
wherever your middle school starts or
the elementary ends is a totally
different ball game
you know so
representative
thank you very much Rick
um so I'm just looking at my notes and
um
we had the hearing on January 27th we
accepted on March 7th 20 nothing to
retain it
um I'm not showing much on the my
hearing notes other than it being
introduced but I could be wrong on on
that and was wondering because
um and maybe Glenn can help clear this
up too because a lot of the language
here
seems very very much
um you know sort of minutia detailed uh
technical language as long as did it
come from the Department is this uh
something that they're trying to clean
up
um
uh I don't recall actually because there
was another one that I uh submitted
um uh based on a constituent request
um and I think it might have been this
one
um but I believe I I recall from
testimony from uh Miss Davis that they
did have a national
publication that helped them
separate out
class time at the elementary school
level
I thought that maybe someone from the
Department would be here today but um so
so what is what is the problem that this
is trying to solve I guess I'm trying to
um I I believe the uh there was interest
in
um participating in
extracurricular activities
um from homeschoolers and others
at additional grade levels other than
High School
if I'm thinking of the same bill
throw a kiss for it yeah gets rid of
high in schools in public right now
it's my understanding when you talk
about extracurricular or co-curricular
as it spells as co-curricular that a
a person that's a resident of that
District but maybe being a homeschooled
kid
May participate in co-curricular that's
my understanding even at the elementary
level I I see that happening up in my
neck of the woods
so
the original Bill spoke to academic
courses and grades once not your bill
but the original Law spoke solely to
academic courses academic course in the
high school
for reimbursement
right
um I had thought that it didn't extend
down
Beyond even the high school level but my
memory might be faulty in that regard
program we have here in law only speaks
to high school yeah right 0.15
reimbursement right but with in nhiaa if
you are
are successful in your homeschooling
program or in completing the eligibility
requirements of the high school
and a resident of the district you have
to be at the resident of the district
you can't be you know in another
district one can come in and play hockey
in that one big and you know that's
going to be a form of recruiting
um but that that was permissible
um
I just you know
I'm I'm I guess I ain't Glenn am I also
asking how do we do this
in the elementary school in the middle
school I can see it I can see this
happening
um but in um maybe what I can do is uh
I'll text Miss Davis and see if she has
further information on that publication
that she had referred to at one point
that would allow some uh delineation at
the elementary school level
okay
um
yes represent dry thank you
I wonder Glenn you don't go too far away
please he has work to do sorry
hey I hear you so
technically if you take an EFA you're
not a home educated student anymore but
you are still educating at home and
therefore eligible to take place part in
some of the public schools offerings so
this this would take out right this
would so this would favor
you would have to pay for that if you
were taking an EF it receiving EFA okay
schooling you don't get any
reimbursement you can go into that
Athletic program no problem if you have
the eligibility academic and attendance
stuff under control
yeah counts yes but do they count in the
adma regardless of whether they're paid
from the EFA or not I mean so isn't EFA
student who's educated at home part of
this adma account
I I do not believe so
why not because they can still take part
right but they are not actually in
attendance full time at that facility
Well none of the home schoolers would be
right so they're they're not included in
the ADM a or r
I guess I'm asking if you're taking out
home educated students but but keeping
are you keeping the home educated
students who are in efas who are no
longer considered home educated
right home educated and EFA it's again
or the other right if you're a
homeschooler you can participate right
because you're you're not getting any
financial support through the state for
your home schooling correct if you're an
EFA student you are getting that forty
one hundred dollars for the additional
amount of money for a differentiate Aid
component you would have to then pay to
participate in the activities
at school
right and and are therefore not in the
adma
okay because you would have to pay for
doing that so who does this apply to
that wouldn't already be already
enrolled in the elementary in the school
in the public school
if you've taken out Home Educators and
the efas don't apply
if the bill was written I think Margaret
for
it applies the reimbursement to the high
school is already in law you get .15 of
that forty one hundred dollars whatever
it might be right
if you're going to go to the middle
school and this is happening and taking
maybe their U.S history course
the Middle School cannot get
reimbursement for that time the students
in there if they're a homeschooler even
they will if they are in the high school
but we have written this law so it's
only applicable right now to high school
I I think the intent of this and I
wasn't part of it was to allow this to
occur in other grade levels besides 9
through 12.
correct okay yeah
um
I was gonna make a point but now I lost
it I'm still thinking that you have
just cut out the categories all right of
people that are eligible to do that
do you see me do you see what I'm saying
um Home Educators home educated is
crossed out
and efas don't apply so who's who are we
aiming this app
um yeah I
okay sorry um but if I could
um
maybe Mr chairman um am I correct and I
think that we had corrected the
situation uh maybe last year that
um the 0.15 was only reimbursed to the
district if there were funds available I
think we we made a statutory change that
it would always be paid to the district
I believe that's the case yeah the best
my knowledge I remember doing that
I remember fiscal talking about it and
finance approving it
Rick yes so how does how would this
work
let's say um
a student who's
Sue is eligible to have access to
curricular courses
um for 193.1 colon c I suppose I need to
look at that and who was enrolled in a
school board approved Public School
Social account is an additional 0.15
pupil for each such academic course
taken in a public school how would that
apply to to a student who may be
attending a public school out of their a
school board approved Public School
outside of their district and is paying
tuition
and this applies in the first category
of adma the kid could participate in
that school's program if it's an open
enrollment School
well I'm just saying we just we just
passed House Bill 275 which allows
School boards to um to approve tuition
agreements with with other Public
Schools outside of their District so now
we've got a situation here where a
student is a member of an adma so
they're not a member of an admr they
don't live in the in the resident
they're not a resident of the school
district they're attending but they're
attending this school district and now
the on a tuition basis from a sending
district and um and they're getting paid
tuition from both the sending district
and maybe from the family as well and
they're getting an additional 0.15
um in in um
adequacy funds from the state
I'm just saying I I think this would
read this would allow that
foreign because it says school board
approved Public School
does it say a public school in their
District
I'm just trying to tease out the corner
case yeah on this
so uh so if if uh if a student if a
student in a district
is attending a public a public school in
another District that's been approved by
the District of residence school board
on it for a tuition program
that the the the out of District school
doesn't receive adequacy for that
student they receive tuition from the so
the the admr
School receives an adequacy payment
yeah but not the adma school
not the school where the students
attending right this would seem to make
the school that the students attending
receive
why would they
why would they request this additional
.15 when they're already getting the
tuition which is
the adequacy money from the resident
District paying for about tuition I
don't know
I don't think they would well I think I
think they'd get it anyway because they
don't have to request adequacy adequacy
get it anyway it's compelled by the
state yeah
the payments are compelled by the state
yeah
I can't I don't know I think that's a
really outside type thing I don't think
that
personally
why would that receiving District be
even looking for that when they're
getting the compensated for the kid
being in that class they get it anyway
it would just arrive as part of the
adequacy payment I'm not saying it's big
dollars
um but
but I I guess I'm
I'm sort of Lost in the
in the purpose of
there the receiving School
is going to get a dma funding based upon
those kids
are they're going to get admr we changed
that they might
Mr chairman um
according to
193 colon 1-c this only would apply to
um non-public public charter schools or
home educated pupils not those
necessarily
public students tuition to another
school district
okay uh
um
is that the site on 506 page 506
yes yes
well does anybody have a problem with it
saying grades one through twelve
I do
I don't know how to be fine
yes I spoke with my local superintendent
and she came to that same conclusion and
we were discussing making it maybe
seventh grade seven to twelve
because those would be classes assuming
Middle School was seven seventh grade
and up
seventh and 8th
but she had she had the same problem
with you're going the old high school
well she she had the same problem with
trying to Define classes in the lower
grades I agree with you then Katie I
agree I it should be either 6 through 12
or 7 through 12.
um well I go back though that uh Caitlin
mentioned that uh go back to the point
that uh Lynn made earlier that there was
a that that national definition for
courses
and that was that I think went beyond
just
the categorical science Etc
and I don't what they may be talking
about here
is that if in fact
in a fifth grade class for example
they're going to have a
a computer uh keyboarding program
or something
that a child could come in for that
program
or even a language arts program
or a foreign language program
I think what she was trying to say here
that there was in fact a way you can
Define the general education categories
even at the
K the k-6 or at least one sixth area I'm
not trying to defend it I think that's
was a point she was trying to make them
that you can in fact in elementary do
some segmentation around categories and
it's not just all general education
stuff
am I
you can answer
something
okay
okay sorry
yeah
can you see the next page when
um representative Milo where you
mentioned the computer I mean they were
talking fifth grade now I mean I taught
the computer class in fifth grade where
I could have homeschoolers who would
commands
um at the time so I think it
could be that long okay great so so
excellent question so where did this
originate does this originate from this
doe this language
weren't sure no one knows
okay thank you but Mario using that as
an example
and based upon your experience in
schools was that it was fifth grade the
thresholds for starting keyboarding Etc
yes and there was there was there was no
other uh they might have had a feed on
it you know 10 minutes in class but the
people the class it was called computer
literacy started in fifth grade so there
was no program for example in logo where
the kids were learning to do some minor
programming Etc well there might have
been absent the kids were able to get on
but it wasn't a class you know what I
mean they could have during
uh Flex time or whatever done something
like that but in terms of an actual
course and that's pretty standard it was
um I think that's pretty yeah I think
fifth grade I was
but
a lot of people are assuming kids are
coming knowing how to do that stuff now
yeah you know they probably have kids in
the second grade to know more about
computers than I do
that's true but it might be what not
what we want them to know well that's
true too I think this is the fifth grade
was I mean it was a course it was it
wasn't just keyboarding it was
um you know using office using Adobe
suite using using all these different
programs to produce
to produce not to play do you have some
homeschool students come in New York uh
yes
so that would qualify then under this oh
yeah
Rick yeah another technical question on
this so at the top of
of
um
190 38 and Page 753
um it says in this subdivision and that
starts out all the definitions
um
is the subdivision is the subdivision 38
or is the subdivision 198.
I think the smaller of the two
so if you follow 198.38
to its conclusion
everything else looks like it's been
taken out of it 19838 is just definition
yeah it's just been wiped out I didn't
look at that
another plug for the book
[Laughter]
[Music]
so 198.38 set the page of top of page or
yeah 753 okay and then you turn the page
it's definitions 38 198 38 and it starts
out in this subdivision
so these definitions only apply to this
subdivision whatever subdivision means
and then you flip over and uh
198.38 pretty much ends on the bottom of
753 and then it has
notes of what's been hacked out of it
over the decades
and then it starts in on 198.39s
and I think 198.40 would probably
benefit from many of these definitions
like English language learner
I don't know from my experience as an
elementary school principle for years
and years and years
and in different states
I saw if you were talking about a course
like reading language arts
sometimes that can extend
Beyond in the social studies
where you're doing a thematic reading
book maybe in conjunction with what
you're studying it's in in the social
study side but it's also written in in
the reading level of those that you're
trying to teach
um for in comprehension skills detailed
skills are out are all taught so the
classes it's
classes are not like they are approved
courses in the high school where they're
approved those 43 courses are approved
for graduation credit
in the middle school you can take one of
those courses if it's offered in
advanced you know an advanced you know
you could take out for one down there
and your your sport recognizes that as
an approved course
but there's other courses which are done
in the junior high school where student
students move
they've moved to different teachers they
moved to and that's that's pretty common
and pretty typical
is it that common for an elementary kid
to move from their third grade class to
somewhere else other than for art or
music or PE
they get it all that's why an elementary
teacher is credentialed as a k6 K8
Elementary teacher
they can teach it all
in the high school and and we hope it's
in the middle school too and we we had
those issues oftentimes before where our
Middle School teacher wasn't getting
credit for teaching the same course as
the kid in the high school the teacher
in the high school because they're just
doing a different about teaching exactly
the same course they didn't get
reimbursement for that
so but dropping this down in the
elementary school I think we're opening
it up to a disaster
of interpretation
of abuse
uh
I I I I really I I you know I could I
could tolerate what Katie mentioned by
talking to her boss or who's her
superintendent
um I I know who the boss is you're the
boss but
um where it's you're specifically taking
that course in science
it rotated to that class you're taking
the science course
that's easily identified the school
should get a 0.15 for that because the
kids coming in taking in that the class
school is getting nothing
I concur but I I have a hard time
swallowing down to the grade school I
really do I think we got we're opening
up Pandora's Box to
where's the start and stop is it going
to be all day long is that the one
course
uh what are you gonna do in kindergarten
when the primary thing everything I
learned in kindergarten is what I need
for life and here you have the
kindergarten teaching social skills in
every class and where's math start and
stop When you're counting blocks and
playing
all right so you're suggesting that a
school might only get credited for 0.15
even though they're they're
instructing a kid for a in a full-time
basis
possible
that could be a course that could be you
know that's why we have we had a
definition everything is what does it
say in a course program or grade
uh we Define course and program
differently than we do grade we have
grade there simply because we got the
grade schools
and though that is the curriculum
asking if I had concur or not concur
it's up to the instructional
organization of that school figure out
what's best to convey the curriculum in
the instruction
um
it's easy in the high school we're able
to do that to remember the school boards
Association testifying on behalf of that
saying this is easy to identify and it
should occur
we had a discussion in the middle
schools at that time because we didn't
have it really clearly defined but I
think you can at the middle school
whether it's grades seven and eight the
junior high school or six seven and
eight but remember middle schools also
go down to grade four
Glenn you look like you're back to
testify again
um uh if I'm correct and I think you
pointed out Mr chairman that um it
currently is 9 to 12 in statute
um so if if you want to
um amend this to you know begin at grade
six or whatever
um and bypass the uh difficulties with
the class structure at the elementary
school level I I think that would still
be a step forward for for many
what about the co-curricular stuff
I take the word co-curricular out of
that because they
go ahead
we started homeschooling it was up to
the school district whether to allow
home schoolers to be on their teams or
not
and it does it's not an academic
program I think I think I agree with you
I don't think those rules are you're
right and that's set up by n h i a a
they require you've got to be in
attendance a day prior to being in that
sport if you were missing that date
you're not going to play in that game
and we've had state championships won
and lost that way uh but to
I think that
the issue of sports is I think taken
care of through that organization
and we do have kids coming in also and
that are homeschooled that are welcome
to play
in the middle school or the grade school
activities
they're welcome and they are too but you
know I I I don't know why co-curricular
is in this well but co-click it can be
more than just Athletics
I mean it could be the chess club
it could be theater theater band
yeah math outside but is the is the is
the school would the school be getting
credit 0.15 credit for the co-curricular
no they
have curricular stuff that's not part of
adequacy
that's extra that's why they call it
extracurricular you've been saying that
for some time and and some school
districts charge a fee for the students
participate in the extracurricular
program
they boil it down for maybe eighty
dollars to high school down to twenty
five dollars twenty dollars they turn
that around and that's where they get
their stipend money for the instructor
or the coach
es money is not in adequacy the PE
teachers money's inadequacy
so so are we going to reimburse them
the 0.15 which is coming out of that
adequacy area
now we're going to have that funding
extracurricular activities I think we've
got to be careful
if if
the coach's salaries are the same that
when I coach to get Pennies on the hour
so that's a big piece the big thing is
the fields the facility which would be I
don't know how the facility would fit
into it but the use of the facility the
equipment and the uniforms that's
basically
uh the biggest cost I think for for
co-curricular extra curriculum that's
where you have to have a genius as a
principal figuring out how to write how
to do that right and a coach and the
athletic director that's their
baileywick and that's why you see kids
wearing old uniforms sometimes because
then they're not at that price yet and
that's why there's soda machines in the
back hall that's why on my soda machine
in my elementary school which was about
500 kids I took annually from that
machine eighteen thousand dollars
it's huge money and then if you're in
Texas and if you have a contract with
Pepsi you better not have any Coca-Cola
in that school that's right
nothing good
the teachers have been canned for that
we tried to get no pun intended but uh
so what we're really talking about here
then the problems we've got with this
is the elementary program
the co-curricular
so if we were to move
if we were to move if we were to mend
this
to
that's you mentioned sixth grade to 12.
for curricular programs
would that then solve the kind of
conversation we've been having so
I'm just trying to reach you're moving
towards that goal I'm trying to just
read some kind of conclusion here okay
okay Lindy thank you
if we're looking at line
three and House Bill 625
um and then compare that to the students
who are eligible to have access from
section 193 colon 1C which is referenced
here we could eliminate
um
access to curricular and co-curricular
we could just say eligible to have
access to
um
public school programs per RSA 193 colon
1-c then we would
we wouldn't start getting into the weeds
over what's co-curricular
because it's already defined in 193.
colon 1-c
as part of the definition
the local school board shall adopt a
policy regulating participation in
curricular courses and co-curricular
programs
so we don't have to redefine it
necessarily
we can just reference
the other RSA
makes it simpler I think
we don't know where this came from
we don't know where it came from but do
we have a specific problem like one can
can someone give an example of a school
or give an example of when or why it
should be changed
yeah yeah did Glenn say that this was
filed on behalf of a constituent
the department had had people contact so
I think that his father to happen to
hearing from the Department
that there's that was concern but
what's the problem yeah
and middle school isn't as as delineated
as high school is I mean it you may be
able to kind of wheel out that they have
a math class for the math teacher but
they set up in Pods at least over where
we are you know the groups that and they
may have Matt you know math integrated
with something else I mean it Middle
School is kind of all set up to be
Innovative and
uh interconnected rather than high
school where you take a chemistry class
and a physics class and you know math
class so I think Middle School is not as
delineated and as easy
it would be a protagonal junior high
school the old Junior but uh I tend to
agree on that but I think you could
it be worth investigating it if it's not
six through twelve seven through twelve
um we have a lot of k-6s buildings too
which are still in there all working
together all those grades
perhaps what we ought to do is is uh try
to find out a little bit more where this
came from
why it was put forth
uh
we had this discussion once before when
it came to the Middle School
and we looked at language which
identified the 43 courses that we
required those have to be up those
courses have to be approved by the
school board
the course in the Middle School do not
so you can teach any which way you want
most of them get in some form of block
scheduling
so
Mario
well unless they're getting if it's in
middle school and they're getting high
school credit for it right was the other
issue that I brought up we have that we
have eighth graders taking the high
school court and it's got to be the same
as the high school course yeah they
can't do whatever they want and I think
that's only fair that if they're if
they're teaching a course as the high
school teacher would teach it and
people credentials and all that and
that's it's approved by that board for
graduation there should be a
reimbursement of a 0.15 for that course
it's a good point
so Rick yeah um
you know I think it makes sense to get
um to get some clarification on what the
problem what what what what uh
precipitated this
built to come in
um I think I would also like to get some
clarification on what it means at the um
at the top of what chapter you end 198
38 198 753 what it means when it says in
this subdivision all these definitions
whether that stays with 38 or whether
that continues throughout all 198
um and I'm also interested in in the
distinction
in both you know both sections of this
why the public school is is referred to
as a school board approved public school
um
why is it a school board approved public
school as opposed to a public school
what's that truck back here
94.
because that's not the District of
residence
and and
193 colon 1C I think talks about the
District of residence
yeah
I'd have to look through this thing a
little bit more
I think we need a little more work on
this
before we can do anything I think we got
some marching orders here
what to do with it
so with contact Doe
try to get some more information
regarding this in 198.38
um
I saw somewhere in here where
the course has to be approved by the
local school board
to be one of those 43 courses
I think that's in rule as well
but
so let's let's not take any action at
all now I didn't plan on taking the
action anything here today
um
is there anything else we need to do on
this right here I think we need a little
bit more work and more information from
Doe
thank you
yes okay good okay what's the next one
we ought to take out 37 637.
similar issues
6 37
yes
okay this was a doe request I guess and
I also have a commitment that
representative opposite yep
you just say six three seven six three
seven
yeah there is a there is an amendment
difference
yeah it's uh Amendment 143
h
mm
yeah
there was
143.
I've got two of them right here I can
give one away if somebody needs
to make my binder less full
I think I need the same class yeah it's
the same thing yeah it's exactly the
same clarification I'm reading it the
same way basically I I would I would
think of you
if we get Caitlyn here or whomever
they can answer the questions regarding
both of these
because I've got the same question here
how to determine the elementary
curriculum
how do you define a course
and then see this is applicable only
originally to the home educated students
yep and I think it's got to be
applicable only to that student yeah
not to an EFA too
so this one right here this amendment
would be easy for me to change just you
know scratch a whole lot of stuff out of
there and and make it uh
approve public
not not in the amendment
if you look at B there it still has
who was enrolled in a school board
approved public
High School academic course
in a school board approved
it could be a high school course that
leads to graduation or something like
that a high school approved course in
grades
eight or seven through twelve
so then you're taking that approved
course that's board approved for
graduation you may be taking it early in
the middle school but you can get
reimbursed for that program
if it's taught in grade seven or eight
anybody underneath the amendment
you got it then I got it too
to you can say something like this for
the purpose of calculating any DNA each
pupil who is
home educated in compliance with that
RSA
and who is enrolled in a school board
approved Public High School academic
course shall count as an additional
0.15
you can take the high school course in
the middle school mission
An approved High School course leading
to graduation or something such as that
that's the early ads for Algebra 1 you
would get credit for
other words we're only opening up still
to courses that are approved at high
school at the high school level but
maybe are taught needs great
that goes along with competency
education a person's ready for that
should be doing that
not just until they get the high school
how does the current law prohibit that
from happening
well because this says
and I don't think it does prohibit
unless the definition of high school
specifically says 9 through 12 somewhere
I've looked up that definition there
right but it but it's I I was I was I
sort of re reassessed how I was reading
um school board approved
High School course it's a school board
approved course and it can be a high
school course
and it doesn't have to it doesn't mean
that the student has to be on grade
level
that's right
I mean it's just the student is taking a
high school board approved High School
course
see they have under 193 E3 Dash f
approval of courses and programs
and it says the principal or other
administrator of a high school shall
Grant credit toward High School
graduation
for similar courses of programs have
been satisfied satisfactorily completed
at other public school approved schools
or shall provide reasonable
justification for denial
so
it goes on and talks about Vermont and
Maine and all of a sudden being in a
tuition School
but the
I would
if they're going to get credit for
graduation I would think that the high
school principal would have to
approve that course that's being taught
in the eighth grade or at least the
school board would have to somebody
wouldn't
that the well the school board approves
it as as part of the program studies for
the high school
right and we have kids that can graduate
from high school in three years time if
they're got it all done they're ready to
go to college yeah we've I mean I think
everybody probably has something we have
some middle schoolers that are taking
High School courses yeah
um
well the two bills are the same they
really are I think it goes down to what
what what's what's what what what are we
trying to fix here yeah
would it be worth contacting a school
administrators Association and finding
out
how this would be perceived by high
school principals I I think it's worth I
mean did did this
this came out of the department did this
bubble up through the department to
Glenn and then I can't remember which
one they're both almost the same
language representative Hudson said this
was from the Department yeah so so we
should find out what the complaint was
from the Department
we don't need names but
yeah
yeah let's do that that goes on in that
thing I just read it says for purposes
of this section approved schools include
all New Hampshire Public Schools
this is 193
e colon 3
Dash f
it's underneath adequate education
yep there's only one thing in that whole
thing that's just approval of the
courses
we need to get some history on this one
more from the Department
we've never asked the department what
would happen if you have an eighth
grader that's taking an approved course
in the eighth grade towards graduation
could they get reimbursed for this the
0.15
the district would get the money not the
school that would go to the district
anybody got anything else for this
they're very similar the same thing
that's why we have them under the same
committee yeah
okay what else do we have to do
okay what else do we have to do that's
it that's it that's it
for today
could have cleared up outside too yeah
look at that yeah just in time
you can go walking tonight
anything else
okay let's close it down what we'll do
is we'll come back after we get some of
this information
I'm gonna call Caitlyn right now and ask
her that question about taking High
School course in the eighth grade
I don't know are they still in public
comments
thank you
yeah you've got slumps in the back all
right you can head over you're gonna
head over to
you go around in a car for carry them or
drag them
you pull them
so far
well you've got the three wheels
that's good you're walking
foreign